[Musique]
Véronique que l'on retrouve Michel David
Michel c'est Auger bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir je vous ramène à jeudi soir vous
avez marqué un but Michel David je viens
de parler de hockey
mon collègue
vous aviez dit à notre débat à notre
panel la semaine dernière pour qu'on a
les moyens de payer nos des petits
pêcheurs que ceux des autres provinces
mais qu'on n'a pas les moyens de payer
nos enseignants aussi cher que ceux des
autres Provins ça avait créé ça a
beaucoup circulé en fin de semaine ce
tweet là les gens vous ont repris tout
ça poser la question et vous avez posé
la question vous-même dans une table
lors d'une table éditoriale avec Bernard
Drainville on écoute un extrait et on
revient
au Québec
qui ne gagne pas suffisamment je suis
d'accord je voudrais leur donner plus
il y a une négociation qui est en cours
présentement
puis
c'est pas le spot je trouve que la
comparaison est un petit peu boiteuse et
si je m'appelais Michel David je dirais
qu'elle est un tantinet démagogique
pourquoi donc
postulerait
tu comprends vraiment les job
d'enseignante à la job de député là tu
étais en train de me dire que ça se
passe
ce que vous avez ajouté Michel parce que
là il y en avait pas tout le temps de
tout passer c'est assez long vous dites
non ce que vous disiez c'est que vous
compariez les députés que les députés
puis les enseignants que les enseignants
des autres provinces
pas que Monsieur Drainville méprise les
enseignants comme comme beaucoup de gens
l'ont dit au cours des dernières 24
heures mais je pense que tu es pris de
cours par la question mais comme vous
dites je l'avais déjà lancé alors
pas mal circuler quand on arrive en
entrevue normalement on se prépare
évidemment il y avait pas vraiment de
réponse qui qui ne ferait pas de
dommages parce que s'il y avait dit bah
oui c'est vrai ça a pas de bon sens
qu'on paye nos enseignants moins
qu'ailleurs alors qu'on paye nos députés
plus cher ça aurait voulu signifier que
il condamnait l'augmentation de salaire
que l'Assemblée nationale s'apprête à
voter mais il y a des réponses qui sont
moins mauvaises que d'autres et à la
fois les propos de Monsieur Drainville
et sa gestuelle
ont créé une commotion qui est pas de
nature à l'aider lui à
comment dire
avoir la collaboration des enseignants
pour sa réforme et évidemment ça
collecte du Trésor qui doit négocier
renouvellement des conventions va avoir
probablement misère à expliquer ça au
top de négociation on va l'entendre tout
à l'heure sa camarade au trésor qui se
dit vous faites exprès les amis de me
mettre dans l'embarras Véronique parce
que moi je suis en train de négocier
puis je vais accélérer le pas avec les
syndicats
ça demande beaucoup de l'énergie des
négociations avec les employés de l'État
c'est un marathon c'est long puis Sonia
Lebel est comme une marathonienne qui
veut faire un sprint là parce que faut
régler mais elle a le vent dans la face
elle a vraiment la face à cause de ses
collègues justement puis aujourd'hui je
trouvais ça assez paradoxal qu'elle soit
la seule disponible justement à donner
des entrevues à devoir défendre et
d'avoir justifié puis Bernard brinville
de son côté n'accordait pas d'entrevue
pour expliquer justement ses propos sur
papier monsieur Drainville un expérience
en communication il a de l'expérience
comme ministre c'est quelqu'un qui est
réputé pour être proche des gens mais
c'est là qu'on voit que
l'expérience comme ministre il était
ministre responsable des institutions
démocratiques sous le gouvernement Marwa
donc oui il avait des employés à gérer
tout ça mais là il se retrouve à la tête
d'un réseau où on a des milliers
d'employés et où chaque déclaration
peut provoquer une genre de crise de
ressources humaines ne peut avoir un
impact sur la mot la collaboration sur
la confiance aussi du réseau alors on
est dans un dans un autre monde et c'est
comme s'il ne n'en n'avait pas encore
pris conscience si on regarde toutes les
différentes déclarations faites dans les
derniers jours chaque chose chaque mot
qu'il dit a un impact sur les gens du
réseau et
quand Michel David il y a des réponses
moins mauvaises que d'autres il aurait
pu dire on souhaite un rattrapage
ultimement entre les enseignants du
Québec et les enseignants du reste du
Canada on va on y travaille et puis on
espère franchir une étape là les députés
on partait de loin et puis là on fait
comme certains échelle enfin un peu
bonus parce que c'est ça
mais il y a aussi dit
pas du tout la même chose que de donner
de plus d'argent députés et tout ça
alors un moment donné c'est vraiment le
côté pour pour les autres membres du
Conseil des ministres c'est la vieille
rengaine là mon Dieu protège et moi de
mes amis mes amis je me charge
c'est soirée dans son propre but pour
reprendre un expression de hockey là
mais
et
comme ça et là il est pas complètement
déprogrammé je pense de son ancien
métier d'animateur de radio j'en ai créé
contre les animateurs de radio
évidemment mais il fonctionnait un peu
de la même façon là quand on déménage on
fait plus on fonctionne une autre façon
on va écouter la réaction parce que
Véronique vous parliez de réseau il y a
beaucoup de gens puis tout est scruté
réaction des syndicats qui sont je vous
rappelle quand même mesdames et
messieurs en négociation
on en entend beaucoup parler depuis hier
puis pour ce qui est du respect de la
profession enseignante les enseignants
ne se sentent pas beaucoup respectés et
encore moins à l'autre c'est très mal
perçu ça a été très mal habile pourquoi
les profs eux n'auraient pas droit à ses
augmentations là et que les
raisonnements qui s'appliquent pour les
députés qui s'appliquent pas au corps
enseignant pour nous ça fait pas de sens
c'est un peu méprisant l'égard de notre
propre profession
parlons-en de l'offre que qui a été
bonifié donc faites aux employés et au
réseau de l'éducation enseignants on
offre un 12000 dollars Véronique pour
ceux qui auraient pris leur retraite et
qui resteront une année de plus
personnelle la santé 143
[Musique]
alors Véronique donc on augmente quand
même la cadence là on le voit absolument
puis le montant forfaitaire de 12000
dollars en soit il est bien accueilli
mais il arrive trop tard selon les
syndicats parce que les professeurs les
enseignants qui voulaient prendre leur
retraite ont déjà rempli la paperasse
administrative il y a un processus qui
est quand même assez long le petit pas
juste un processus administratif c'est
un cheminement mental aussi donc il y en
a beaucoup qui l'ont fait cette
réflexion là puisque ce sont dit c'est
fait je pense à autre chose mais pour
revenir en arrière ça fonctionnement des
quand même
faut revenir dans tout ce processus là
parce qu'il y en a qui sont vraiment
prêts à le faire donc les syndicats
disent il me semble que cette offre là
aurait dû arriver en janvier en février
quand on était en train de préparer la
prochaine année puis qu'on était déjà en
train de planifier les remplacements
avec les nouveaux professeurs tout ça là
c'est comme si le jeu est mis en place
puis on nous demande de recommencer à
zéro donc ça arrive trop tard selon les
syndicats bon Michel et Michel c'est
doux puis on revient ce que tu veux vous
disiez Michel C d'où dans ces moments-là
tout ce qu'on dit est important faut pas
brouiller les lignes avec du bruit
justement
[Musique]
non seulement les
professeurs qui voulaient partir à la
retraite ont signé leur papier et tout
on a déjà nommé dans beaucoup de cas
leur remplaçant il va falloir détricoter
une grosse affaire alors comment ça se
fait que ça arrive maintenant ça n'a pas
de sens et si vous êtes un enseignant
vous pouvez vous pouvez vous dire ils
sont pas sérieux quand c'est négocie pas
savoir ce qui se passe dans le réseau de
l'éducation comment on s'en va comme on
remplace les gens etc puis faire cette
là maintenant ça a pas de bon sens
Michel oui il est tôt mais ce 12000
dollars là c'est c'est très bien c'est
évidemment ça reste venir avant mais
c'est très bien pour ramener un certain
nombre d'enseignants temporairement pour
une année dans le réseau mais pour tous
les autres qui vont continuer au cours
des prochaines années ça donne
strictement rien ça ça améliore pas les
offres du gouvernement pour eux et de
sorte je pense pas que ça influe
beaucoup sur l'attitude des syndiqués
face aux offres du gouvernement
et de cette façon-là ça règle rien la
même chose pour les primes ça dure pour
le reste de l'été si je comprends bien
mais pour les années à venir
sa règle rien non plus alors je pense
que c'est un coup d'épée dans l'eau
est-ce que
Sonia Lebel
a quand même ce qu'il faut politiquement
parce que ça va quand je dis les taux
les c'est que ça va vraiment s'accélérer
c'est des grandes manœuvres est-ce que
elle a les moyens de ces ambitions
est-ce que les moyens de régler ça d'ici
quelques mois Véronique
en fait il le faut même si Sonia Lebel
dit non ça a pas d'impact sur la réforme
de Bernard drinville en éducation non ça
a pas d'impact sur la réforme de
Christian Dubé en santé toujours est-il
que il y en a un impact indirect c'est à
dire que son argument c'est que la
réforme de Bernard brinville c'est une
réforme de gouvernance donc on n'a pas
besoin de mêler à tout ça les employés
du réseau pour ce qui est de la réforme
de Christian Dubé comme ça va commencer
à s'appliquer en 2024-2025 à ce
moment-là on va peut-être même être dans
une autre convention collective dans une
autre négociation
ultérieure mais entre temps faut pas que
la confiance s'effrite parce que c'est
ça le nœud de la faire pour que ces deux
réformes-là fonctionnent ça prend une
collaboration des deux réseaux puis
cette collaboration là se construit au
fil des années au fur et à mesure qu'il
y a des négociations donc oui elle doit
se dépêcher à régler pour que ça se
fasse pas de manière acrimonieuse et si
je peux ajouter quelque chose le
problème de fond dans les deux réseaux
c'est la pénurie de main alors quand
vous entendez le ministre de l'éducation
qui a l'air de dire que finalement c'est
pour Babet important cette profession-là
ça donne pas envie à ceux qui pourraient
avoir la vocation de
poursuivre alors c'est une très mauvaise
pub pour pour la réforme de Monsieur de
Monsieur denainville vous me donnez
l'occasion Michel de vous montrer la
mise au point que Bernard drinville
envoyait sur Twitter il n'y a pas donné
comme disait Véronique d'entre vous
aujourd'hui mais il a parce que il y en
avait assez d'entrevue il a dit en aucun
cas j'ai voulu insinuer que le travail
d'enseignant a moins d'importance que
celui de députés à mes yeux toutes les
professions et tous les métiers méritent
le même respect qu'on soit enseignant
infirmière machiniste plombier etc donc
mise au point mais
la moyenne canadienne elle est
implacable c'est un fait que le Québec
paie moins que la moyenne canadienne ces
enseignants sont on en sort pas le
Michel d'où votre remarque qui a du poil
bah écoutez c'est 16000 dollars de
différence en moyenne des enseignants au
Québec sont payés 16000 dollars de moins
que dans le reste du Canada et pour
poursuivre la comparaison avec les
députés l'augmentation de salaire des
des membres de l'Assemblée nationale va
faire en sorte qu'ils vont gagner 10000
dollars que les députés de l'Assemblée
législative qui est la plus
lucrative c'est-à-dire l'Alberta alors
les chiffres ne mentent pas et les
enseignants vont les regarder mais c'est
aussi que cette augmentation de salaire
là si on compare justement avec les
autres provinces en fait le Québec c'est
la seule province il y a des allocations
de dépenses donc vous devez en plus
ajouter les allocations de dépenses qui
fait augmenter davantage le salaire
comparativement aux autres provinces
annuels au Québec annuels et donner en
bloc dans les autres provinces et des
systèmes de remboursement plus compliqué
très bien je vais vous parler de
quelqu'un qu'on a connu
dans le monde universitaire mais aussi
dans le monde politique qui voulait être
chef du Parti québécois on écoute un peu
la Cour suprême avait joué un rôle
politique n'est ce pas au moment du
rapatriement de la Constitution je pense
que j'ai prouvé cela dans ce livre et ce
livre a évidemment fait un gros tabac
triste nouvelle pour sa famille pour son
épouse pour ses enfants Frédéric Bastien
très jeune 53 ans qui est décédé d'une
crise cardiaque il était un combattant
pour le Québec on sait il avait aussi
j'allais dire une obsession mais c'est
pas péjoratif sur le rapatriement et
fait la bataille de Londres un livre est
allé éplucher je pense qu'il y avait un
coucher tout ce qui existe comme
document au monde sur le rapatriement
Michel C un petit mot autour de table
sur Frédéric Bastien
d'abord vous avez raison de dire
certaines historien engagé il s'écrit
présenté d'ailleurs après la direction
du parti québécoise pour pour rien en
même temps c'était remarquable par ce
livre de c'est que il est allé à Londres
voir des affiches du Conseil privé
là-bas de tous les organismes
gouvernementaux qui ont dit oui vous
donner ça ce qui s'est passé dans le
cadre du Canada de ville bien sûr il y a
pas de problème ils étaient là à tawa
alors on avait dit être très intéressant
par ailleurs on peut on peut critiquer
certaines conclusions mais où on avait
toute l'histoire vu de l'homme qu'on
l'avait pas celui de Ottawa
peut-être que ça nous dit quelque chose
sur des sur la façon dont on retraite
des documents officiels en tout cas pour
les historiens c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle ça ouais Michel ouais sa
tentative de prendre la tête du Parti
québécois bon pour fonctionner mais j'ai
quand même trouvé que c'était très
courageux de sa part monsieur Bastien
était professeur d'histoire au collège
d'Orson vous savez au collège
le parti le plus populaire
alors ça avait été assez audacieux et
d'ailleurs il préférait qu'on insiste
pas non plus sur l'identité de son
employeur parce que il savait très bien
que ça posait certains hommes disons un
malaise à l'interne au-delà de son livre
qui était fascinant il y a continué par
la suite à critiquer disons le
militantisme des juges de façon générale
au Canada de la chartiste comme on dit
qui à son sens je vois systématiquement
au détriment du Québec alors à tous
égards c'était un militant qui était
extrêmement tenace c'est je me souviens
je l'avais qualifié de Pitbull un moment
donné quand il décidait qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui avait pas d'allure il
y avait rien pour l'arrêter il achète
pas
avec grand respect j'ai eu la question
de l'interviewer à plusieurs reprises et
quelqu'un oui il était très très
convaincu de ces de ces thèses ces idées
mais très respectueux aussi on peut
parler après de des enfants et d'autres
choses Véronique mais je me rappelle que
son livre avait fait beaucoup de tapage
ici au Parlement d'autant plus que c'est
le gouvernement Marois à ce moment-là
qui était au pouvoir c'est sûr que les
coulées puis les documents puissent sa
façon d'écrire le livre ça avait fait
réagir c'est pas tout le monde qui était
d'accord avec disons ça méthodologie ou
ça sa manière de donner les faits mais
toujours est-il que à ce moment-là on en
parlait pratiquement pas lors du rap
même si c'est un gouvernement pékiste au
pouvoir en parler plus vraiment là du
rapatriement constitutionnel donc lui il
a ramené quand même ça à l'avance scène
et offrant en sorte que des gens qui ont
pas vécu cette époque-là ce sont mis à
s'y intéresser alors c'est un grand
défenseur ça je pense que c'est assez
unanime c'est un grand défenseur de la
nation québécoise c'est sûr
qu'aujourd'hui toute la famille péquiste
on le sent là et vraiment deuil un idéal
et un grand il y avait quelque chose il
partait puis il allait combattre puis il
arrêtait pas Véronique Michel c'est
merci beaucoup au revoir à très bientôt
au revoir